[Music]
springing Jay Bilas the former Dukie of
course working for the mothership is
their basketball analyst but but before
we get to Grayson Allen J we just had
the Greek freak pronunciation game and
didn't know if you would want to jump in
on that see it took me four years to
handle sure chef ski I don't know when
it be giannis attenti kun bo is that
right did you say
Yanis or giannis I said Yana okay and
you did a bow not a PO I did a bow okay
yeah I I think I think bill is I think
bill is probably the leader in the
clubhouse it's wrong yeah strong entry
right yeah that that's good yeah but I
think this is like this is like finding
a ball you know golf ball in the woods
it's substantially substantially similar
rule as long as it's close enough I
think it works
and while Jason Kidd came on a couple of
weeks ago he said he didn't even know
how to pronounce his last name
yeah well coaches I mean you know this
coaches are horrible at pronunciation so
if you ask if you have to coach a how do
you pronounce this guy's name they'll
tell you oh it's like this man the SI D
comes up later said no that's not what
it is not even close
he says he calls him GA or he just calls
him by his number but he doesn't call
him you know
Gianna's santa to khumba how could even
get through all that is pronounce it
correctly
why would you go to those lengths know
that yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't even I
couldn't even go that's why that's why
it's Coach K I mean why you know why
would you go through the moshevsky Creek
chef he although you know print it you
know that pronunciation problem and all
those syllables if you can just say K I
was surprised last night when I tuned
into the game I didn't tune in the
beginning of Duke but I wanted to see if
grace Nell was on the bench and a suit
and tie what you know where would he be
during the game and then all of a sudden
I tuned in and I see me in the uniform
how surprised were you obviously you got
a heads up but how surprised were you
that he was back after one game you know
what I didn't get much of a heads up Dan
I came from the Wisconsin Indiana game
so I didn't I didn't get there to be
able to see practice or anything but
when I saw him in warm-ups dressed the
same as every other player like a lot of
times too
hours before a game I get there about
two hours before and a lot of times
you'll see guys going through individual
work with a coach or a couple of coaches
but then you know so yeah grace Allen
did that but that wasn't any indication
when he came out with the rest of the
team he's dressed like everybody else in
his regular warmup gear than I do okay
he's going to play and but we didn't
find out he was going to start until we
got the the official starters like you
would 15 20 minutes for the game so he
sits out one game and you know just to
give you my opinion earlier in the show
I said that this if it feels like we
want justice as sports fans and I said
look if coach Kay he's the one that has
to dole this out whether I like it or
not it's his house his family his team
his player and I think there's more
going on behind the scenes than we'll
ever know so it's one game I think
losing the captaincy is pretty humbling
and embarrassing for him your thoughts
on a one game suspension again this
one's kind of stumped me honestly this
is one of the weirdest things I've ever
seen in basketball not just college
basketball but basketball I've never
come across this kind of thing where
it's you know guys are a guy
intentionally trips somebody and does it
three times within five months or
whatever the time frame was it was just
it's weird and you know it's kind of
like it's unsportsmanlike or conduct
unbecoming you don't even know how to
categorize it because it's so weird and
and so when it happened the second time
I was one of those that said when Coach
K didn't suspend them there was there
was a lot of hand-wringing over he needs
to be suspended taught a lesson and all
this other stuff and my thing was okay
well how many comedy games then it you
know so zero seemed to be reasonable
with me he got this reprimand from the
league the league didn't do anything
about it
you know the officials didn't do
anything about it in the game so I was
okay with that the third one I kind of
thought okay now he's got it he got a
suspended we got to do something but I
was wondering to myself well is it
because of me or is it because it's the
right thing to do for the the kid or for
the the school because there the public
opinion is important in this I think and
so I felt like the best thing to
for Duke would be suspend the kids so
that the kid could move on and if you
know otherwise we're gonna have this
constant discussion about it and the kid
wouldn't be able to get out from under
it because I don't it is just my
personal opinion dan I don't think this
is this is some sort of rational thought
where you can say okay now he's learned
his lesson because if he didn't if after
all the the storm of criticism that came
to him after the second one and all that
came with that and it was not pleasant
for any of them he would do it again
means you know I don't think he had
necessarily control over it and I'm not
look I'm not saying like some do it's a
question what's reasonable because I'm
not saying well some Duke fans will say
it was some involuntary leg spasm you
know I don't I don't I don't agree with
that but then you know you go outside
the walls of the Gothic Wonderland and
there's some unreasonable people there
to that think he should be incarcerated
or get a ten-game suspension or not play
to a tournament or all these things
we've heard mine is is is it reasonable
I happen to think that this the way it
was handled was within the bounds of
reason I probably would have gone a
little bit longer but the fact that
Coach K is getting surgery on Friday I
do think I don't know how much it
factored in but it clearly factored in
and bringing it back now and it
certainly took a lot off of the plate of
Jeff capable and the staff and the
University and having to do something
while Coach K had stepped away I just
wondered the ACC's rule in this je and
if we make this you know player X for
the Miami Hurricanes and he's had three
different incidents here is it is it
handled differently by the ACC as
opposed to leaving it up to Coach K C I
don't think it would be handled
differently by the league I think the
league gets involved they consult with
the school's the league doesn't want to
do any of this stuff they don't want to
be in the business of handing down
punishments and reprimands and all this
stuff they don't want to do that I think
what you do at least what I do is you
look at okay what have they done in
other cases now there's no case like
this one and and I don't mean to say
egregious or how horrifying it was or
all that
this one's just weird I mean I don't
know what other word to use for it it's
odd but if you if the league starts
getting into that it starts becoming you
know then
start becoming the the the arbiter of
all punishments for things like that so
you know first it starts with the
officials then it goes to the school and
then the league gets involved do I think
that the league looks a little bit wimpy
in this yeah a little bit but that then
you get to a public perception issue I
mean the kid got suspended we get our
sake like one thing I do not listen to
and that's when you know any idea that
would come from Duke or any other school
that is being criticized is that we
should keep our mouths shut it's none of
our business because if we are or we're
not qualified because if we're qualified
to praise we are qualified to criticize
because nobody's ever called me and I'm
sure nobody's ever called you and say
hey listen you are not qualified to keep
this much praise on us keep your mouth
shut
I've had enough you know so when we're
critical you know we're reasonable
people and in our criticism is reason
they may not they may not agree with it
it may not be right to them but but it's
reasonable Jay Bilas from the mothership
joining us are you pro or anti court
storming in in I really don't care but I
do think I do think it is somebody's
gonna get hurt and it there is a
dangerous aspect to it it is not part of
the game it's part of the it's become
part of the atmosphere I do believe we
in television are a little bit to blame
because the court storming and every
highlight of an upset and it makes it
look like a something that should be
done like we don't show people who run
onto the field during a game anymore
we used to but we don't and it's that's
been a long-standing policy now for a
number of years but the reason we don't
is because we don't want to encourage it
so are showing it means we're kind of
encouraging it I don't think it's part
of the game but it is part of the the
atmosphere around the game as part of
how we sell the game but you know when
somebody gets hurt then then they're
gonna do something about it it's kind of
like remember when people used to rip
down the goalposts yeah
people got hurt doing that and it got
expensive too but I you know now they're
finding teams that do it like you know
Butler's gonna get fined by the horizon
land not their eyes only the Big East
they're gonna be fined by the Big East
and I you know those kind of things I'm
not sure that works or even matters that
you're dealing with the universities do
and how they how they handle security
and all that stuff with their own
students I don't I don't know that
that's that's worthy of a fine but
that's another that's not that's another
thing we're getting into where you know
we're judge and jury on whether you know
how a conference should act I'll leave
you with this how many teams do you
think can win the championship this year
I would have said eight or nine earlier
in the year but it but I don't know that
the top teams are as strong as I thought
they'd be there are they're all really
strong in there in in certain areas but
they've got a couple areas where you go
boy they're not as strong as I thought
they'd be in this area they don't defend
as well and they don't guard the post as
well they don't rebound with stuff like
that I do think that if Duke gets
everybody healthy and in some kind of
rhythm they've got the best sort of
roster but Villano has got the tightest
group UCLA is the best offensive team
Kentucky is the one that scares me or
that would scare me if I had to play
against them because they're their
guards are so good they just don't shoot
it that's the only thing they don't do
but they do everything else and and they
could be and then West Virginia scares
me because of the way they the way they
can be disruptive defensively it's gonna
be fun toward the end because there are
a lot of legit teams that are really
good but there's nobody that is head and
shoulders just yet Thank You Jay always
great to talk to you pleasure is mine
Dan great to be with you buddy the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]